packaging connoisseur time I love this  pump top you don't really see a lot of  pump tops in Asian sunscreens but I am a  huge fan of them it just makes it so  easy to apply a consistent amount and  you don't accidentally just keep on  applying less and less over time without  really noticing also most importantly  the pump top is flat like the tube so it  doesn't actually take up extra space in  my makeup bag it looks round in a lot of  the product photos so I was actually  kind of confused when it came in like a  flat standard Korean sunscreen box I  thought maybe I was thinking of the  wrong product because I'm really  unobservant and that explains a lot of  things in my life I don't know why flat  pump tops aren't more of a thing this  just makes so much sense to me